ami let me start with you your character
I'm curious as to the the sense of
damage that the character has someone is
very lonely loneliness almost referred
to in the film as if it's a disease or a
condition something that Bob's character
immediately denies having alone but not
lonely is that something that was just
inherently in the script for you because
I think in the performance is a
wonderful sense of that that damage that
yeah I mean I looked at the script I
thought she must be pretty [ __ ] up um
but I one of I will always remember a
really important moment truly as an
actor where I you know had had very much
thought along those lines and I thought
well she's you know probably forgot a
little damage you know daddy's tough
call incest go I don't know like you
know why would she know I mean not that
you're not fabulous I mean at the
beginning you know um but I remember
saying to my client Michael that's
either the research that he said chest
tell me everything you're thinking
around I said some of these things and
and I will always remember this and
Michael looked right at me and he said
no she just falls in love with him and
it was really a beautiful moment and you
know I thought um you know as most of us
here I was a huge fan of last Mohicans
and I was like well anything this guy it
was a surrender and a sort of letting go
into into a romanticism and a mythic and
I thought oh I am I am the aspirational
hope you know of a person like Bob and
I'm a person in my own right but I I
sort of let go of a certain
psychological dissecting and really into
the hands of of the whole thing and um
and I also yeah it's funny watching that
scene because you know one of the
appeals about Edie is she's so unguarded
I mean she's really known and you sort
of defend against that idea of
loneliness she's like no I can admit
that you know people need connection so
um I think that was probably how she was
designed well Diane for you because
keratea playing I think extraordinary
difficult
to pull off a man did a wonderful job
with it because is it's paradoxical
because she's somebody who in some ways
is not self-aware and is unaware of
what's going on with a daughter at times
and seems unaware of the nature of how
the relationship is playing out and at
other times he's able to articulate with
real resonance who this guy is and what
he's doing and what's going on on his
head and how did you how did you juggle
that how did you balance that I just
played it fair enough
just what example the way something is
written Michael wrote it so beautifully
that there could be traps in it for me
so when Alec came into the restaurant we
talked about his physical movement we
don't see this in the cut but he came
into the restaurant like like a like a
dancer in a way what kind of off-balance
and I was so mesmerized by his entrance
which wasn't on film at the time that I
could see he was angry so when he sat
down I thought it was a different kind
of the scene but there was such anger in
him that in the moment I remember just
go underneath and just love him so
that's all I did
that's great Michael - you have a
wonderful part wonderful supporting part
that sort of has many small moments of
of exactly what a supporting character
needs to do in those moments and then I
think gets just this this is wonderful
moment with our child at the end where
outlines you know a child's future and
what that should mean her as a mother I
just want to say it was great
but I also wanted to know what what
memories you had of getting to film that
that particular scene where that was
done I mean all films have been done
almost entirely on located entirely on
location I believe you know where was
that scene that's Venice Beach that's
finished
okay what memories you have at that well
I I I was really shocked that I got the
job in the first place that true story
uh Michael I love Michael so much I'd
seen Michael in November and then like
February of March I get this call from
my manager that Michael and Al Pachino
want to see you and I was on the way to
it I was going fishing man I just picked
up some true story I just picked up some
ghost to shrimp of all things to go
fishing
and sure enough I go to Michael's office
I doubled back go to Michael's office
and then I've had the privilege of
within half an hour al shows up and and
the story I got from Al is you got
robbed you didn't get a nomination for
Forrest Gump and they actually had
another guy in the role and Michael and
Al got together paid that guy off and
hired me because I didn't get a
nomination so I'm so grateful for those
guys and but the way Michael works it's
it's my wife can tell you how much I
love Michael Michael can walk up to an
actor on a set and just before he would
get to me he would look in my eyes and
go you got it and I did I don't know how
he put that [ __ ] in my head but he never
do it but he's but you know it was just
a wonderful wonderful privilege to work
with Al Pacino Robert De Niro just the
whole everybody vow everybody's just a
pure class act I enjoyed working with
Ashleigh she listened very closely and
Michael would feed a store he's so
detailed oh my god it's amazing